damit bekommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video und bekennen dieses gerät
unglaublich viele leute wissen einige
leute versuchen auch mit einem halben
meter zu zerschneiden
das ist aluminium macht keinen sinn
arbeit vom zum thema hier seht ihr schon
hitler innenverteidiger heute team
iphone live hacks trikots haben
kennt ja wahrscheinlich die nfz und zwar
kann man dort ja foto vom video team
wieder an freunde versenden oder halten
die story packen während ein video
aufnimmt kann man in der app summen
dabei ist die meisten leuten machen dass
wir gut unterhalten runden gedrückt mit
einem daumen und film dann klar wieso
mit den mit den daumen in den finger und
dann die nun heißt du und das treffen
umstellen will damit allerdings mit ganz
einfachen trick und zwar könnt ihr
einfach eure finger hier drauf packen
wäre die ein video auf dem könnte den
finger einfach hochziehen das heißt
dadurch könnt ihr quasi mit einem finger
zoom möglich noch mehr finger
gleichzeitig auf den screen packen
ich würde mal sagen
400.000 gleich allein für diesen typ
schon
mit vita heilige trapping nachricht an
einen kumpel oder irgendwas die notizen
oder streit beispielsweise eine mail und
irgendwie machte dann alle vom ball
zeigen nicht nur kopieren und löscht es
dann komischerweise durch einen fehler
oder keine ahnung war dass ich mich zum
beispiel mit ein paar monaten gedacht
okay mein gott es damit gelöst jetzt
passiert muss ich mir auch mal schreiben
allerdings gibt es eine ganze hilfreiche
funktion von apple und baby schon okay
ich habe jetzt viele male hier steht
hallo bitte lasst den daumen hoch und 1
ab und lässt aus versehen und ihr
doppelpack ich habe diese medaille
gehört da könnt ihr einfach schütteln
und dann geht ihr schon eingabe
widerrufen und wenn wir nur mit dem
finger auf widerrufen klicken wie schon
die male einfach ja da ist und dafür
nicht nur in mail sondern auch bei
anderen sachen gegeben hat dann hat es
gelöst haben könnte quasi nationen
rückgängig machen
der dritte lag bezogen auf das iphone
hat etwas mit mir zu tun und zwar um
genau zu sein mit der aussprache von wer
kennt ja wahrscheinlich gesagt wir mit
den und denen an und dann spricht mit
den namen noch mal auf und denke wow
wie kann man aussprache verpacken einen
komplettpreis ausgesprochen und betont
dahinter nämlich die funktion dass ihr
direkt wie sagen können es war falsch
macht das mal neu und ergibt sich
nämlich mit ausbaumöglichkeit und ihr
könnt dann auswählen was richtig
arbeitszeit gleich das ganze mal einem
beispiel patrick kontext und jetzt kann
ich beispielsweise sagen ok patrick hat
die beiden ausgesprochen das ist nicht
die richtige aussprache wir ihn
gesprochen
mit dem integrierten adresse und jetzt
bei wir ihnen nämlich vier möglichkeiten
an wie wir leben meine kumpel patrick
war sie ansprechen würde hat patrick und
der findet viel auswahlmöglichkeiten und
ich kann jetzt auch wählen wir quasi
ausgesprochen werden würde da kann
formal eingeben immer noch mal sprechen
auf jeden fall könnte damit direkt sagen
okay wir weiter ausgesprochen macht das
mal bitte richtig und kann dir denn die
rag war sie beibringen wie man redet und
wie man leben
das war
relativ bündelung war hatte jeder die
iphone app installiert wenn wieder nicht
gelöst hat und in der komplett sieht man
eigentlich nur ob lakers und kompass und
da wo ich hingucke wird nur die
himmelsrichtung und die gradzahl
angezeigt allerdings könnten nach rechts
leiten und dann dieses sonderteam hier
eine wasserwaage habt jetzt kann ich da
eine art erweitert werden ein bisschen
könnt ihr auch wenn das jetzt hier eine
wasserwaage ist wie ihr euch hier
anzeigt ob gerade das heißt sie kommen
von apple nicht nur einen ort von 1
weiterhin auch eine wasserwaage
vielleicht ganz sinnvoll wenn man keine
zuhause hat
besonders cool verleugnet die relativ
faul sind also wie und könnt ihr einfach
mal in eure einstellungen gehen und dort
unter allgemein tastatur und texte
erweckung findet ihr schon wo ein menü
überzeugt worden ist aber ich habe
gehört angelegt und ich habe mir ganz
ganz viele wörter ein gegeben die ich
beispielsweise nur kurz die buchstaben
andeuten müssen dann werden diese durch
wörter ersetzt wenn den weil ein handy
beispielsweise den ich gegen dann bist
du eigentlich der letzten gv die el tri
bekommt eventuell wenn ich die wahl frei
bekommt irgendwann also das besonders
gut für faule leuten die auch keinen
bock drauf haben eines münchner
auszuschreiben
ich weiß nicht wie ich ohne diese
funktion vorher überleben konnte
die palette jetzt bezieht sich auf musik
und war kennt ihr das er verleiht ihr
sitzt irgendwie auch verkaufen und
fernsehen und können dann dort halten
abstand time einstellen beispielsweise
sagt okay und ich will nicht nur eine
stunde gucken danach soll sich der
fernseher abschalten genau das wünscht
man sich natürlich auch vom iphone
irgendwie mit der musik und dass man
dann irgendwie okay findet mit
kopfhörern und wie generale nach stunden
holzhütte ausgehen könnte ganze wie
machen und zwar wenn ihr dafür einfach
in eurer orf gehen und dann auch die
option einer kleben dann könnt ihr euch
hier in time aus ihren wenn ihr dann
hier auf klingelton drücken die ganz
nach unten gehen und auf wiedergabe
stoppen klicken und wegen teilweise
beispielsweise mal auf eine minute
aktiviere wir schon jetzt eine runde der
75 die weckten 50 und beweisen bevor
univega stehen jetzt noch neun sekunden
das heißt sich der von beispielsweise
schnelle notizen machen liegt an und
wenn ich jetzt wieder die entwickler von
ins boot automatisch passiert doch kein
knopf gedrückt nicht gemacht die kirk
war sie einfach musik abspielen oder
einen esata kehle zugedrückt
ausgestellte ich einfach ein timer
stellen allerdings jeden tag erhalten
ist eine stunde
das wär net länger als eine stunde musik
zum einschlafen dann gibt es halt nicht
sieht sich jetzt verzeichnet auch wieder
auf musik und zwar kennt ihr das er
vielleicht hat die mitglieder gegenüber
den spotify mog ein placement für das
lied oder spotify oder die app an sich
meist cool ich musste jeden tag aber es
ist kein geld für ihr habt ihr die
zeitleiste und wie tief erschütterten
neun minuten das halte ich das wort und
will das relativ schwierig ist genau die
zeitung zu finden dafür kann man nicht
einfach in china hoch und jetzt schon
den finger jetzt ihr dann geht es nur
noch ganz langsam da unten voran und es
zu weiteren finger hört und langsamer
geht es weiter ich den finger und das
tier desto schneller geht es wieder
voran und ich kann über eine
wischbewegung direkte zum ende des
liedes kommen das ganze funktioniert ist
billiger.de radioshow ich keine ahnung
erwarten auch alles also wenn ihr quasi
langsam vor schulen oder zurückspulen
finger auf die spur zeichne packenden
auf displays der leiter nach oben ziehen
und dann geht es schon viel genauer und
ihr könnt ihr viel genauer irgendwelche
speziellen teilen prem finden
jetzt wieder etwas vorteile und zwar
könnten den einstellungen unter
sprachausgabe aktivieren das wir euch
einen text vorlesen sollen damit ihr mit
mir selber lesen braucht ich hab jetzt
beispielsweise hier entdeckte meine
notizen app markiert und damit auch eine
seite weiterklicken und kann auch
sprechen drücken
wow ich hab den gleichen text nochmal
ein gegeben allerdings habe ich alle
vokalem weniger lang gezogene patrick
immer noch sprechen
die funktion ist mit ausbaufähig können
festhalten es ist möglich dass sie ihren
text vorliest allerdings liegt die mit
relativ schnell vor das heißt ihr müsst
gut zu hören ob hey leute ich habe
gerade noch mal gegoogelt und zwar kann
man die schnelligkeit davon einstellen
dass wir schauen jetzt mal an dieses
video mit einem daumen hoch
diese leite kann ich euch nicht so
richtig vor 100 ihr das wirklich mehr
leider hängt wenn ihr ein iphone habt
könnt ihr selber mal aussetzen weil ich
relativ coole und zwar wenig hilfe ton
einstellungen da könnt ihr einfach auf
klingelton drücken oben auf die
traditionen und dann könnt ihr nach
unten gehen und wc könnt eine neue
vibration erstellen ist diese standard
iphone vibration einfache wird wenn er
angerufen werde
denn hier gerade denkt hey bieten zu
langweilig würde was eigenes sein könnt
ihr einfach vielen dieses menü gekonnt
jetzt lagen
und dann könnt ihr noch stoppen drücken
und damit eure persönliche vibrationen
die so noch nie da ich weiß nicht ob man
das irgendwie mit krieg ich jetzt ganz
nah ans mikro halte keine ahnung von
irgendwas gehört habt oder so auf jeden
fall könnte damit weitere sachen machen
wie we will rock you oder diese da könnt
ihr halt enorm viel mit rumspielen und
können damit quasi euer handy zu eurem
eigenen personalisierten handy machen
mit mit euren klingelt und
personalisierten klingelton
kommen wir nun auch schon zum letzten
tag den ich mich heute zeigen möchte und
was könnt ihr handy also das ist ja das
was ihr und finger auf den home button
drückt und dann könnt ihr damit euer
iphone entsperren
die können das gar nicht so laut im
internet angeblich mit eurer nase machen
also ihr könnt einfach in die partie
einstellungen gehen und dort dann
einfach euren finger auf länger für eure
nase auflegen das ist nicht gut wenn er
beispielsweise in wie durch die stadt
laufen teilt raus und eure daumen bin
irgendwie bereit eingefordert und baten
abkommen sportler sorgt einfach die nase
auf den home button drücken dann
funktioniert da kann ich euch damit
wirklich zeigen weil ich da für mich
irgendwo hinsetzen müssen oder sogar um
ständig ich wollte das ganze doch erst
mal klickten an meinem ein laptop
aufnehmen darf er als dankeschön
einblenden kann ob er ahnung was mit dem
ich allerdings das iphone die im kursaal
und minimiert wird nicht mehr also apple
was soll die scheiße
das war nicht meine damen und herren
endlich die fahrertür ich mich über den
daumen auf euren schatten hier wird die
1000 leid für dafür dass sich in der ohl
anteil bei 38 minuten denn oder auch
nicht ich weiß um dieses videospiel
minuten geschnitten habe man dank kurzen
statement eben von mir zu dieser minuten
brachte dass man damit word anzeigen
schalten kann und so ich verstehe nicht
wieso ich leute darüber abfahrten dass
andere leute jetzt längere videos
hochladen zum beispiel bei mir was ja so
dass ich nur video hochgeladen habe die
luft wir fünf minuten gingen oder kamen
enorm viele kommentare und hey
kommentare darunter engel und macht auch
ein längeres video wir wollen ein video
über zehn minuten gehen soll ich dazu
noch eine umfrage gemacht und am meisten
über 90 prozent wollen lieber längere
videos flächen beiden tagen video einen
tag im video dann noch vier minuten und
jetzt mache ich diese längeren videos
und mache dann dementsprechend hat auch
werbung für mich noch besser
arbeitsaufwand ist die witze anderen
zehn minuten video insgesamt immer so 14
stunden und ich die videos auf jeden
fall länger frisch wenn die leute
in die videos langen also passiert also
ich würde lieber andere youtuber sehen
wir jeden tag den themen video hochlädt
und der hochheimer werbung dazwischen
die nach dieser künftig und was bringen
kann als er jeden tag nur fünf minuten
video hochlädt wo ich meine werbung
gucken muss also denk doch mal nicht an
euch die verständnisvoll will und das
zeigen aber an die leute die nur meckern
von biegen euro in zehn minuten video
wurde mit der werbung seiten kein hemd
ist damit auf den härten er konnte aber
aging integriert weil die eingeblendeten
brauchen könnte meinen kanal abonnieren
kostenlos und ihr braucht keine videos
mehr von mir und hier findet ihr ihn ein
anderes video eingeblendet klingt doch
mal drauf